matt nice to meet you yeah
uh did y'all register for credentials we
did we were denied and
i okay multiple times so i'm just hoping
i can talk to someone
from the
[Music]
uh my name is john stanton i'm the
washington bureau chief for buzzfeed
news
i have been a reporter since um
god since february of 1997. uh
so almost 20 years and i've worked with
at buzzfeed since
july of uh 2012.
[Music]
uh what are we doing today today we're
in phoenix arizona
for uh donald trump's uh big rally here
uh
and we are going to attempt to cover him
as journalists
it's like we've never been given
credentials as a news organization to
any of trump's campaign events
and um they won't tell us why he's
potentially going to become the
president united states and people
need to know what he is about what
happens at his rallies
what happens with him and then the press
needs to be allowed to report on him
exactly we have to know do we have to do
that we have to be able to get in the
room to be able to tell them what's
going on
no one this has never happened before i
mean there are plenty of politicians
that i've written about in my life
that don't much take care for me or
don't really like the stories that i've
written about them
um but they never banned me from their
press events
well there's there's a number of this so
there's buzzfeed washington post
politico
daily beast um i believe the national
review
has been banned it's a pretty sizable
list
media
the volunteer that uh um was at the desk
you know asked me
whether or not we had credentials told
that we had been denied and wanted to
see if i could speak to someone
uh about why we've been denied and so
after you know
five minutes or so um um a woman who
works
for the campaign on the advanced team
her name is uh hannah salem
uh came outside and spoke with us as far
as staff is here now it's all advanced
currently right now and so um we're you
know that's that's out of our lane to
make that decision
when will they get here that i can talk
to somebody that is not advanced
i i i can't speak to child schedules
basically told us that she could not
tell us why which is not surprising
because i don't think they would
probably know
and told us that i have to talk to hope
hicks who is the sort of communications
director i guess for the
the campaign um she's also happens to be
the person i email every time this
happens
um to us when we try to go into the
events and she's never once responded to
us so anyway you could
call somebody or an ass find out for us
like so
i understand that so hope is the person
you should be speaking with
and i've tried that's with my it's like
showing up in person so that
hopefully one time i'll catch her right
right um if you want to give me a card
or something like that
i'm happy to to pass that along to her
and relate your message to her
we asked if we could come back and they
basically told us no that they wouldn't
be around
but we gave her my card and maybe this
time
hope will call me because i honestly
just want them to tell me why and really
she's going to let me in
so i can sit in the press pen with the
rest of the reporters and watch them
give a speech
[Music]
[Applause]
you